even in a virtual world it's a subtle
and not so subtle barrage a classmate
asks your Asian friend to tutor him for
his math exam because they just know
math am I right microaggressions bias
and blatant racism you know the Muslim
guy a Shen Abdullah
a deal though this is just an avatar her
words are representative of everyday
discrimination he's so touchy about his
name you know that sounds racist right
in VR Alice and other avatars are tools
to help users examine unconscious bias
pointed out and then call it out they
are a door to help people go into a room
and help people start the conversation
Michael Avis who is an educator and
technologist was curious to see if the
immersive world of VR could be used in
anti-racism training an idea that was
reinforced during the pandemic it's
Black History Month I'm sitting in my
kitchen all three of my kids are at home
and I get to hear what the teacher is
saying to my kids and that's where I
started to think Hmm some of the
language that I heard was problematic
there were a few things that I really
didn't like after that experience
Michael and a group of black fathers
with similar concerns made a video to
share their stories they also offered to
be a resource for their kids schools we
came together today just to have a quick
conversation about having our kids grow
up black in East York and being part of
the education system I'm just curious
about what you heard that was so
troubling to you there was a lot of sort
of they in them statements and the
teacher she's a wonderful teacher she
was not trained to have these
conversations in diverse communities
like Toronto how do we help her think
about the languages she's using and
that's where it all came from so Michael
reached out to body swaps a VR and AI
company based in the UK that creates
software that allows users to practice
difficult skills before entering the
real world and together they created
let's talk about race a series of
modules tackling microaggressions bias
and privilege virtual reality is very
good at putting you into that situation
and feeling of visceral empathy or
feeling a connection so if you can
combine that empathy and that emotional
connection with practice that's really
where you have the really effective tool
this tool is designed to help identify
and verbally practice addressing
Prejudice in real time think about the
financial backing that your parents
provided to you it even analyzes words
used when confronting a bigoted Avatar
then provides tips on how to approach
that situation in the future how do you
think virtual reality differs from
training for example I've been in races
in racism training before and it's been
a bunch of people either online or in a
room where nobody really feels
comfortable talking and that's a real
challenge so how can we really have a
conversation if we're not comfortable we
don't have the right language we're
worried that we're going to say the
wrong thing this training is different
because it's personal and done alone
psychological safety is the number one
thing if you can't speak to truth
yourself in a room by yourself then
you're never going to do it we got to
see firsthand how it worked we met up
with Michael at a Toronto Catholic
Elementary School where he was training
staff you're going to go to a private
place
where no one else can hear you and
you're going to interact with this
software okay so we're going to get set
up you can sit right here I think it
would really suck to have people look at
the color of my skin and assume that I'm
here to do them harm being treated with
suspicion all the time must really
affect how you feel about yourself and
did you find it valuable 100 listening
to just even my response I thought oh I
could tweak things add more so it was
good at times I definitely felt myself
getting worried about what my own biases
were but I think the prompts were really
helpful to help me overcome it so far
Michael has shared it with dozens of
companies schools and Healthcare
networks it's a put up or shut up moment
I think don't create these systems if
you don't actually have any action in
mind I think that this even if it's a
small piece is very action oriented it's
about changing Behavior it's about
practicing on your own there are a
number of different VR platforms
available challenging beliefs on Race
diversity and Equity I thought virtual
reality would help me offer that
difference in perspective but also
capture subtleties of racism that are
difficult to explain if you haven't
experienced or encountered them in 2016
associate professor Courtney Cogburn and
a team of social workers from Columbia
University collaborated with Stanford to
develop a VR program called 1000 cut
Journey look at your reflection in the
mirror take one step closer and examine
your new body we wanted to capture
structural aspects of racism it starts
very early in life it cuts across every
facet of one's day and it occurs Across
the Life Course Mike
Mike and me I shouldn't have to tell you
not to throw things in the classroom in
one thousand cut Journey participants
embody a black male Michael Sterling can
I help you as he faces racism as a child
an adolescent and a Yale graduate in the
workforce you must be our candidate from
Yale uh no sir Mr Murphy Mr Sterling is
our candidate from Yale it's about
observing white racism from a black
perspective which is a really different
orientation and one that I think helped
keep us in this place that made it
really rich and powerful and not
reductive and not about entertainment
and not about performing as a black
person as a black Avatar
Courtney has been studying the effect
the VR experience has had on those
who've tried it and if it achieved a
lasting impact I think it's a catalyst
for change but insufficient in isolation
get down on your knees and put your
hands up but I think what we've
accomplished is that it changes people's
relationship with racism the research
found the study group made up of white
liberals had changed their perspective
on the issues of race even 14 weeks
later there's this shift from it's a
thing I'm observing out there and it's
now a thing that I see myself as a part
of so I think there's something about
the VR that's been really powerful in
shifting that perspective I've found
that people are also more open to
difficult conversations once they come
out of the experience all right so how
do we do this we wanted to try the
training so Michael set us up with the
microaggressions module okay so all
you're going to do really is just use
your hands like you would normally you
see the little arrow on the right yep
it seemed pretty straightforward let's
take her at one point I had to identify
and classify different types of
microaggressions But as time went on it
became more challenging that comment I
made about a dill scholarship his
family's loaded and he gets to have a
paid scholarship because he's a minority
I had a lump in my throat when I had to
confront Avatar Alice on her racist
remarks and for some reason I felt like
I was being personally attacked but I
had to put all that aside because the
software was now asking me to disarm her
and get her to reflect on her own bias
by you saying that he's lucky to have
that Diversity Scholarship makes it seem
to me that you think that he only got it
for that reason now Adil also has really
good marks he's worked really hard so by
you saying that it makes you kind of
dwindle him down to just his race and
for people who look like a deal or who
look like me that is insulting because
we're so much more than what we look
like on the outside so next time think
about someone's skin color first maybe
think about
what else they've done to get to what
they've achieved all right is that half
an hour yep wow how did you find the
virtual reality compared to sort of
traditional learning that you've done it
was a lot more immersive versus a you
know a PowerPoint or a module where
you're just listening to someone
speaking and also challenging my own
perception thinking that I was really
good at this because I've done a lot of
this work and then when I was put on the
spot not being able to find the right
words in that moment I think that was
really eye-opening did you find any of
the parts of it triggering it was
interesting to me how guttural it felt
and how angry I was at what was
happening in front of me even though it
wasn't real I felt the Injustice in that
moment and it was like the whole face
palm like how do you not understand what
you're saying is racist or troubling
um but I think the most effective part
was when I was put on the spot to have
to call the person out right that's
uncomfortable for me I'm not somebody
who likes confrontation so to put it in
a way that disarms people when I I'm
already at and at that level is very
challenging there's now more awareness
of racial Injustice and inequities but
Solutions and real change still need to
happen while Michael says these issues
are complex and VR alone won't solve the
problem he hopes these immersive
experiences could help us reflect on
ourselves and the language we use to
create a better tomorrow what happens in
six months when I'm kind of forgotten
about some of the tools I think that
this is a piece of the greater amount of
work that needs to be done so for
companies institutions I say to them you
know you're not going to just give this
to people and say we're done now
nobody's a racist or we understand bias
we understand privilege no this is the
the seed so that it needs to have
continuous work for ever